uh there's some interesting news which
is uh it's good news but it's also not
nearly enough new york is going to be
raising the age to buy an assault rifle
from 18 to 21 and new york is going to
be banning body armor um widely reported
including by bloomberg governor kathy
hoechel and legislative leaders pledged
to raise the legal age to purchase an
ar-15 assault rifle in new york to 21
from 18
and pass a package of measures to
tighten gun laws before the end of the
state's legislative session this week
citing the mass shootings in buffalo new
york and uvalde texas local officials
say they want to close loopholes and
address the gaps in laws exposed by the
back-to-back massacres the bills would
prohibit the purchase of body armor for
civilians require a license to purchase
a semi-automatic rifle
make threatening mass harm a crime and
strengthen the state's red flag laws the
measures would also require new pistols
to have micro stamping technology which
uses lasers to implant mark imprint
markings to make it easier to trace guns
to registered
owners
illinois washington hawaii and florida
have already raised the age from 18 to
21 for assault rifles so this is great
right but
neighboring pennsylvania you still only
have to be 18 to buy an assault rifle in
neighboring new jersey you still have to
be only 18 to buy an assault rifle
and in new jersey adults can buy and use
bulletproof vests and body armor unless
you have a felony conviction and in
pennsylvania there are no extra body
armor regulations besides federal laws
so in pennsylvania adults can still buy
and use bulletproof vests and you could
say well but david it would be against
the law to cross state lines or right
yeah but it's still extraordinarily easy
to do and so you get the idea we need
some kind of broader
probably federal legislation on a lot of
this stuff now
one of the things we have to remember
is if the crime is going to be where
there's more population and work we've
got a piece planned on this issue of
um
the the gun violence is in so-called
democrat cities you all know as i've
explained before
cities in general lean democratic and
high crime cities and low crime cities
are
basically run by democrats democrats
just live in cities and crime is more
prevalent where there is more population
density so
we might understand well the population
centers are where you're going to see
more crime but if it's that easy for
people to go to jersey and pennsylvania
for the weapons or to go from chicago
into indiana
this type of thing might actually
backfire statistically in what shows up
good for new york city good for the
state of new york but we really need a
national effort here now in terms of 18
versus 21
i would actually go to 25 on uh
semi-automatic assault weapons now you
might say but david why not ban them all
together sure i'm trying to be realistic
to some degree
and when you look at the ages of many of
these mass shooters
you have a situation where you've
overwhelmingly got shooters under 25
using a semi-automatic
assault rifles so you could deal with a
ton of the mass shootings specifically
by targeting those firearms in those
individuals now of course we should be
doing much more and as i've said before
what you do to deal with gun suicides
versus individual gun homicides versus
mass shootings three different problems
three different sets of solutions we
talked about this tuesday on the bonus
show with pat but this is at least one
thing that can be done and uh you know
unfortunately in my interview in the
last segment
congressman jamie raskin was not super
optimistic that this time it's going to
go differently in terms of getting
republicans on board to actually do
something but
even though it's not enough
even though it doesn't go far enough
even though it's not happening in enough
places to make a difference yet
new york is at least doing something
listen canada is doing more as a result
of mass shootings in the united states
than the united states is doing and
we'll talk about that on the bonus show
what if you could get through an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
blinkist takes top non-fiction books in
every genre boils them down into a text
or audio explainer that you can consume
in 15 minutes of course blinkist would
never replace reading real books in
their entirety but blinkist lets you
absorb the most important insights from
the non-fiction books you wouldn't
otherwise have time for i have a ton of
different ways i consume information and
blinkist is one of those and it's super
efficient i just used blinkist to listen
to the book toxic positivity
super interesting just about this like
happiness obsessed culture that now we
live in got through it in 15 minutes
with all of the key points blinkist also
takes tons of popular podcasts and
creates a 15-minute explainer for each
episode and blinkist really just
empowers you to grow by discovering new
ideas knowledge that will give you
valuable new perspectives about the
world go to blinkist.com pacman to try
blinkist free for seven days and you'll
get 25 off a premium subscription that's
just 6.25 a month the link is down below